[Música]
y
después de lo que hemos vivido durante
esta pandemia por kobe 19
como médico tengo
una pregunta o quiero hacerles una
reflexión qué pasaría si las siguientes
generaciones no estuvieran interesadas o
no tuvieran la voluntad de seguir
asumiendo el reto de ayudar a los demás
de exponerse por los demás
concretamente si se acabará la vocación
de servicio y cada vez fueran menos
quienes quisieran hacer parte del
servicio de salud de ese valioso talento
humano en salud
5 millones de vidas nos ha costado en
este periodo la pandemia porque hoy 19 y
el impacto ha sido muy fuerte en el
recurso humano que ha sido insuficiente
especialmente en esos picos tan
desbordados que hemos visto alrededor
del mundo talento humano insuficiente y
comprometido a un riesgo que según el
director de la organización mundial de
la salud en la última asamblea
dice que 115 mil profesionales perdieron
sus vidas atendiendo pacientes durante
la pandemia
las condiciones laborales no han sido
las mejores ha habido insuficiencia
también de dispositivos para protección
propia luego adicionamos todo esto al
temor que se puede tener por contraer
una enfermedad y por llevar este riesgo
a mi familia el impacto emocional y
mental que se tiene que asumir por las
pérdidas de vidas al no tener recursos
ni medicamentos ni terapias que hayan
sido efectivas contra este coronavirus
el talento humano en salud ha sido
determinante en las crisis de la
humanidad guerras desastre naturales y
conflictos y estoy completamente seguro
y espero que ustedes también que piensen
que estas cifras hubieran sido
completamente peores si no hubiéramos
contado con la ayuda del personal
sanitario
estamos hablando de 8 mil millones de
personas en este momento con una
cobertura de salud insuficiente
hay una proporción o una relación de 1.2
a 1.4 médicos por cada 1.000 habitantes
según el banco mundial
hay países con altos ingresos en que
esta relación puede estar por arriba de
3 o 4
pero en países de muy bajos ingresos en
áfrica subsahariana o en asia meridional
y probablemente en algunas de las zonas
de nuestro país y de la región esta
cifra está por debajo de 0-2 de 0-3 que
va a pasar en el 2050 cuando
probablemente sí estamos seremos 10.000
millones de habitantes en el marco de
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
de la onu está este planteamiento de
garantizar la cobertura en salud pero
que estamos haciendo que están
desarrollando para garantizar eso
innovación en salud esto viene siendo
determinante que es innovar innovar es
establecer o desarrollar vías que me
permitan la equidad social que potencien
el desarrollo de los países
y esto tiene que estar de la mano del
estado de las empresas y de la
integración de los grupos y de los
centros investigadores para buscar estas
soluciones ante los problemas que se
presentan
innovación social involucra parte de
estos conceptos desarrollo de modelos de
procesos o de productos que me ayuden a
solucionar la problemática social que me
mejoren las condiciones actuales ante
las que se están enfrentando y que
disminuya especialmente el riesgo en
esas poblaciones más vulnerables y más
expuestas
si hay innovación en salud no podemos
desconocer y negar desarrollos
tecnológicos aplicados a escenarios
clínicos y quirúrgicos que mejoran
procedimientos diagnósticos o
terapéuticos
intervenciones y disminuimos la
mortalidad de nuestros pacientes lo
buscamos constantemente
pero hay un concepto en el que no
estamos enfocados en el que no están
preocupados y es el talento humano en
salud probablemente hay desarrollos de
tecnologías e inteligencia artificial
que puede superar a las capacidades
humanas para predecir la aparición de
una enfermedad antes de que hayan signos
antes de que hayan síntomas pero esto
que es muy importante no desplaza el
talento humano en salud y esto la
pandemia y las guerras y las crisis no
lo han demostrado que debemos evaluar lo
que
necesitamos considerar mirémoslo en el
mercado ya lo acabo de decir hay una
deficiencia en la cobertura sanitaria
necesitamos entonces mantener a los que
ya estamos haciendo nuestro trabajo para
esta tarea de responsabilidad social que
es la salud pero aparte de eso
necesitamos incrementar nuestro pie de
fuerza tenemos que mantenernos con
personas interesadas en hacer parte de
esta gran tarea y cómo lo vamos a hacer
necesitamos conocer sus necesidades
saber cómo están las condiciones
laborales que no son adecuadas que son
insuficientes que otros pueden estarse
beneficiando de contratos laborales
mejorar la estabilidad laboral y mejorar
los ingresos de todo el talento humano
en salud es necesario pero también
tenemos que trabajar en la formación en
calidad porque tenemos que aumentar
cobertura pero no sólo un número tiene
que haber buena calidad en la atención
para todos los pacientes incluye los
menos favorecidos
cuando analizamos ese contexto tenemos
que hacer atractivo ser parte del
talento humano en salud
si vemos qué sucede en el fútbol el
reporte de forbes nos muestra como
leonel messi se gana 75 millones de
dólares en un año
médico general en colombia sus ingresos
son 15 mil dólares al año quiere decir
que podríamos vincular 5 mil médicos más
en nuestro pie de fuerza para la
atención de una situación como la
pandemia o para garantizar la cobertura
normal de prestación de servicios en
salud
ahí necesitamos el apoyo de todos
ustedes de los líderes de los tomadores
de decisiones de la misma sociedad que
tiene que ser responsable en el cuidado
de salud para no desgastar al talento
humano y entonces con el apoyo de todos
garantizar esas necesidades básicas de
un trabajo digno estable y reconocido es
una tarea social que todos valoramos el
segundo componente y muy importante la
formación del talento humano en salud
hay
299 instituciones educativas en colombia
dos terceras partes son educación
privada pero de todas sólo 51 programas
son acreditados hay que trabajar en esto
el componente en la formación tiene que
ser óptimo porque va a ser en beneficio
para todos
aparte del problema que tengamos
nosotros de la calidad tenemos que
evaluar el costo en la formación que nos
afecta a todas las familias
aproximadamente formar un médico en 6
años que es el promedio del tiempo
cuesta 80 mil dólares en matrícula y
podemos sumar otros 80 mil dólares en
costos como vivienda alimentación
libros algo de recreación que es
necesaria para todos o sea 160 mil
dólares de inversión para un salario de
15 mil dólares al año cuando va a ser
ese punto de recuperación económica para
las familias que se comprometieron con
sus hijos o sus familiares para quien
tuvo que asumir una deuda y poderla
pagar tranquilamente
esta es una de las principales
necesidades donde tiene que haber
inversión a pesar de la pandemia y el
riesgo de enfermarse y los costos y la
situación económica se siguen
manteniendo los interesados en ser parte
del talento humano en salud en bogotá
sobre 44 mil aspirantes al año en el
caribe sobre 35 mil y en el pacifico
sobre 24 mil candidatos al año estamos
hablando que persiste ese interés a
pesar de todas las limitantes
cómo vamos a trabajar información cómo
vamos a garantizar
parte de las propuestas que podemos
nosotros analizar es
establecer un rango una brecha más
estrecha entre la educación pública y la
privada
disminuir los costos de la educación en
salud es un bien para la sociedad no es
un negocio
un segundo componente importantísimo y
es mejorar el acceso a la formación de
médicos y de enfermeras y el resto de
componentes del personal sanitario no
solo quien pueda pagar una matrícula
puede serlo
los mejores evaluados o escogidos
mediante un examen nacional que puede
ser el examen saber debe darnos la
oportunidad para que los mejores
candidatos sean quienes finalmente van a
estar asumiendo ese rol ese reto de ser
parte del talento humano en salud
debemos nosotros considerar que si no
trabajamos en conjunto en conjunto la
sociedad los prestadores los
intermediarios de todo el proceso que
puedan estar involucrados en la
prestación del servicio de salud no
vamos a poder lograr cumplir parte de
esas metas y garantizar la cobertura en
salud
hay recursos disponibles estos recursos
pueden estar generados desde ips ips
industria farmacéutica o compañías que
desarrollan dispositivos que aporten a
la formación de ese talento humano en
salud con becas o con apoyos y que
permitan que los mejores también hagan
parte de las pilas de este valioso
talento humano en salud
tenemos que cambiar tenemos que innovar
y para esto con el apoyo de ustedes de
la comunidad de nosotros que nos
encontramos actualmente
asumiendo este rol y en los líderes que
tienen que apoyar todas estas ideas
tenemos que cumplir esa meta para el
2030 o para el 2050 garantizando la
cobertura universal de calidad con un
excelente talento humano en salud
[Música]
e